[Musique]
voilà mesdames messieurs bonjour
bienvenue à tam tam autour de la table
aujourd'hui maryse jobin bonjour maryse
famille la pertinence bonjour le matin
le mod aviez voilà et marie claude
simard bonjour marie claude à une
émission très riche aujourd'hui mais on
va commencer par un sujet qui a retenu
l'attention de plusieurs congolais qui
sont ici au canada et c'est l'élection
présidentielle le scrutin présidentiel
qui a eu lieu le 30 décembre élection
qui était remporté par félix tshisekedi
et martin fayulu et de était 12e ramasy
chat bary emmanuel troisième c'est le
candidat du président au congo et pour
parler de ces réactions là on commence
déjà à voir nombreuses à la fois au
congo mais aussi au canada se joint donc
un congolais du canada il est président
de la mutuelle des congolais à
l'étranger et s'appelle alex banjo
bonjour alex a il faut qu'on appelle
alors nous allons faire la tête d'accor
alors on va à alex la venue d'un moment
à l'autre
bon alors en attendant qu'alex ce soir
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va peut-être
rappeler les sujets dont ils savent
accueillir la question aujourd'hui
d'abord vous parlement vous allez nous
parler d'une découverte scientifique qui
a surpris beaucoup de monde parce que on
pas souvent des la présence des
antidépresseurs dans le corps humain et
après d'aller dans les ses goûts et ses
hommes n'avaient jamais vu à quel point
les antidépresseurs qui sont utilisés
par les humains peuvent avoir une
influence incidence sur la vie animale
donc je vais vous parler d'un sujet très
intéressant maryse alors vous avez tu
dessus des sujets très surprenant et il
a cessé un sujet qui porte sur un an on
va dire un nom ou un mot controversé ben
en fait oui quand on verse en amérique
du nord blé à une époque en europe ça ne
l'était pas il ya 500 ans
alors c'est quelqu'un que j'ai trouvé
qui s'appelle sébastien [ __ ]
lorsqu'on pense aux monnaies d' en
amérique c'est très péjoratif mais à 500
ans qu'on pense au monténégro qui
voulait dire montagne noire et il n'y
avait alors lui sa famille est
originaire du languedoc
mais damas plagiant lajemmerais pas que
j'aimerais que vous gardiez un petit peu
d'accord mais si le fond de fuir c'est
très intéressant comme sujet donc on va
envahir revenu dans un instant le temps
de savoir si notre ami alex bauer
bonjour alex l'accès à l'eau alex est
souvent tant d alex bonjour oui aux
jambes aujourd'hui voilà donc vous êtes
en direct sur radio canada international
alors je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de la mutuelle des congolais
de l'étranger et alors alex bon on sait
ce qui s'est passé dans votre pays
d'origine la république démocratique du
congo ya eu un scrutin présidentiel qui
était très attendu certaines personnes
se demandaient si c'est discuter aura
finalement lieu et b et là il a bel et
bien eu lieu et les résultats ont été
annoncés par les résultats provisoires
annoncés par la commission électorale
nationale indépendante et alors vous
donc comme citoyen congolais vivent à
l'étranger
quelle est votre première réaction à ce
que vous avez pu entendre jusqu'à
présent quelques minutes qu'ils
m'accordent pour que je puisse donner
mon opinion je sois passé chez nous au
congo conseil général c'est qu'il
convenait de m cris est finalement
aspirent au changement des puits et les
deux ans qu'ils ont été
et un délai pour avoir cette élection
officiellement motivée les congolais qui
vous avez vu que ces fortes exprimées
largement sous le dernier fonctionne pas
ces choses là voilà donc la date
indéterminée et on a eu un premier nom
donc celui de félix tshisekedi qui était
désigné comme candidat
cambrai wenger selon les résultats
provisoires vous qu'est-ce que penser de
ces résultats la rdc fait un million
trois français nous avaient km² 21
millions d'habitants
vous imaginez pas combien les congolais
étaient déterminés à aller voter et la
famille nous a proclamé les résultats
2010 a été poliment les canaris gagnant
nous avons pris acte des résultats
mais les vrais de vrais problèmes
expliqué il ya une contestation une
contestation qui est légitime d'abord
mais également qu'ils aient fourni
beaucoup d'éléments je vais le prendre
ici rapidement à 5 ou qui la conférence
épiscopale du congo qui grandes
organisations catholiques
n'oubliez pas que l'église catholique
secouée entre être déterminant dans
notre société au courant absolument
l'année et quand son coup d'éclat qui
est représenté par l'enseigné ne sont
pas confondre à faire ou à refaire elle
a collecté il ya un petit souci d'autant
plus que justement cette scène qu avec
48 observateurs sur le terrain
exactement la fin qu à déployer le plus
dominateur sous terrain dans tous les
bureaux de vote
donc nous nous disons que nous avons
laissé la chance vraiment départager les
résultats qui aura présenté la ceni et
les résultats car copie compilé la
franco et je voulais vous poser une
question toute la controverse et autour
du fait qu' il a fait 10 kw à 5 jours
avant qu'on annonce officiellement les
résultats donc
nous avons servait à une forte j'ai dû
bien poste qui n'était pas justifié de
la part de la ceni ou d'un film qui
était logan qui était outillés sur le
plan logistique à pouvoir connecter
rapidement les résultats
mais ici il a été servi une forte d'une
peau ce qu'il a fini à marquer qui est
tout le monde internet de sa manière je
ne vais pas ici ma voix c'est dans les
spéculations mais cette pause c'est à
moi n'a pas été très confiant pour
priver de convoler
et la plupart la communauté
internationale n'a pas compris pourquoi
la ceni qui est lié développer beaucoup
de temps vis-à-vis de la synchro qui
logistique mois palois était aussi
oublié mais là fini à prix vraiment une
pause qui n'a pas qu'il n'a pas vu le
genre confiance hulot joly
alors ma tante a eu lieu à des annonces
et qui va contester ces résultats lui
dit avoir gagné avec 61% de devoir bon
il demande un recomptage de voix est ce
que vous pensez quand elles recourent
connaissant votre pays le congo est ce
que pensait qu'un tel recours à des
chances d'aboutir alors rapidement le
temps que je vais vous présenter ce film
apporte quelques oui bien sûr oui ok
congo dans ses 17 ans au pouvoir a pu
monter des machines des machines qui
sont en tout cas actuellement sans
contrat
je vais parler de la cour suprême
vous voyez un représentant les
animateurs cette course est 100 % des
gens qui sont pro kabila alors martin
fayulu légitimement va passer au recours
face à la ceni et de voir la cour qui
est pour le risque a dit là dans ce qui
me concerne je pense qu'il y aura de
défense par contre nous sommes confiants
qu'ils lâchent encore les résultats
qu'il a pu compiler et conforter aux
intérêts de la fille ni à l'ama vous
avez une question oui j'ai une question
concernant
l'importance de la république
démocratique du congo dans un contexte
international je crois que les gens
peut-être qu'on la difficulté à se
mettre à comprendre l'importance d'un
pays aussi grand
mais comment vous décrire la place du
congo au niveau africain au niveau du
territoire africain mais aussi au niveau
mondial comme l explique ce modèle je
prends la vie et les coutumes plus grand
ppp plaît à l'afrique
nous avons neuf voire neuf pays voisins
n'oublie pas que les concerts géants
miniers qui aujourd'hui le groupe à 1
50% des réserves mondiales de cobalt 10%
les prix sont des diamants
vous imaginez qu'après 20 millions
d'habitants dans le congo et sans
oublier que la rdc dépassa superficie le
plus que les des tirs de l'union
européenne alors si je prends la
position actuelle de la bce africain la
r dc est au coeur de l'afrique et ça
doit être les pays qui devraient même
dans les loges en économie il exclut
l'afrique
pensez vous un peu au niveau régional ou
bien que l'économie de l'inde et s'est
dit aujourd'hui et jésus et à latence
parce qu'ils ont concédé 10 et kabyle
ait toutes les chances de vraiment avoir
un cm un pays qui a un potentiel
économique énorme mais malheureusement
on n'a pas su qu'il n'a pas à en valeur
rien que la rdc madame avec son
potentiel économique
on en revient je ne veux même plus le
train d'aller à pour donner de la banque
mondiale qui disaient qu'il y en qui la
population congolaise fera main d'oeuvre
qui est aussi en majorité des jeunes ont
soutien potentiel économique énorme
donc pour résumer la rdc à 12d décoller
et doit décoller
nous sommes tous les cons voulait
vraiment fatiguée d'avoir une faute
d'une alternance qui ne dit pas son nom
anglet pas vraiment à moitié
nous voilà alex bon je rappelle que vous
êtes allé aux usa vous êtes le président
de la mutuelle des congolais de
l'étranger
alors alex là il ya cette contestation
de la part de fayoum attentat est
l'outil à l'église catholique qui remet
en question les résultats
est ce qu'on doit redouter une flambée
de violence rare et plus démocratique du
congo
je suis parti qui ne souhaite pas qu'il
y ait une flambée mais les signaux qui
sont devant nous ne nous garantissent
pas vraiment et climat des pays pourquoi
ces signaux passent qui est habile a
visiblement il ne fait pas partie c'est
ça se voit dans ses tracts ça se voit
dans ses déclarations
par ses agissements et ils découvrent
avait en face une population qui a
longtemps attendu qui a exprimé
massivement malgré des conditions que
vous vous avez bien lu c'est vrai que
moi
son voeu des ces changements et vous
avez enfin des machines telles que la
ceni et la cour suprême qui sont dédiés
aux soldes mais c'est kabila
donc il y à fond mais parier qu'ils
aient les jours qui viennent ne sont pas
très facile pour les colonies parce que
d'un côté kabyle a certainement je ne
pense pas qu'il fait partie je ne suis
pas laissée là pas faire ça et de
l'autre vous avez la population qui
attend du changement qui est fatigué un
régime qui ne répondent pas aux
aspirations et qui exprimer librement
le voeu de changement et si la
population ne l'obtient pas d'autant
plus que le président-élu félix
tshisekedi a déjà promis que n'y aura
pas de chasse aux sorcières dans son
sous son règne que l'équipe sortante ne
devrait pas trop trop s'inquiéter ça
s'est passé pas très rassurant ça que
j'apprécie d'ailleurs il était considéré
les très diplomate
mais le coin il a raté
une belle occasion mais rassure qu'on
ait quitté rapidement ici aussi vivent
vraiment les ars des faits gouvernement
tous sont avons vu comment les
gouvernements se comporter les gens qui
ont été activés par an ici les 6
millions dès qu'on les presse qui ont
été massacrés et avec tous les conflits
armés qui ne gouvernement n'a pas pu
maîtriser ou en tout cas quelque sorte
que le gouvernement ici nécessaire avec
passivité et comme c'est celui qui dit
qui lui devrait d'ailleurs donner un
message fort mais en france un message
d'aller chercher comment non seulement
et concilier les congolais mais aussi
les gars qui dit aulas qui a fait
impunité qui est tous ceux qui ont
contribué de près ou de loin à mettre à
genoux la rbc a à tous les communes y
répondre et les actes et quand il verra
qui du coup monsieur kabila
je suis bluffé lycée cuvier connu comme
étant le fils de ben et d'étienne
tshisekedi qui en opposant historique
démocratique du congo le fondateur de
l'huile udps l'union pour le progrès et
démocratie sociale est ce que en dehors
de ça
là une feuille de route il ya quelque
chose qui rassure les congolais comme
futur président comme dirigeant de ce
pays en dehors du fait qu'il y ait deux
fils détiennent six et qui dit ce
qu'elle dit son parcours comme vous le
connaissez on a parlé
il est le fils métier fait qu'aider
le doyen de nos positions au congo neige
effet leaf a fait en tout cas son
parcours en belgique d'après ce que nous
avons appris et personnellement je n'ai
pas eu la chance de le côtoyer presque
et plusieurs la qualité quinzaine sont
aussi en afrique
je le connais les amas dans les
dernières années où il a pu militer à
côté de son papa
on met sur le point de son taux film les
gens les connaissent assez lisse il a
une diplomatie fait quelques uns des
tempes et les inhaler coûte déjà et je
ne vais pas spéculer sur ses compétences
moi j'ai fait des médias
si félix aujourd'hui ils peuvent baisser
innovants les défis majeurs part cela se
voulait comme je ne veux pas lui laisser
la tâche facile
et bien évidemment il ya beaucoup danger
actuellement qui sont en revanche
notamment les âges économique et
climatique
c'est l'esprit donc je mets 10 il fait
les céréales a ôté jamais sa voix j'ai
pas en tout cas en face de moi son
dossier et je pense qu'il devrait bien
s'entourer
si au moins il a la chance et puis j'ai
l'air d'accord et quelle erreur
souhaitez-vous qu'ils ne commettent pas
contenu des 17 années de de kabila
qu'elle quel problème reprochez-vous à
kabila et que reprochez-vous à kabila et
que vous ne vouliez pas n'oubliez pas
que tu sais que dire produisent alors
pour ce qui est des registres et de son
conseiller la première des choses
voudrait voir ça sert et d établir
l'état de durango vraiment être la rdc
en match et donner toute la sphère
l'avait fait parce que nous avons perdu
y a plus d'état des droits nerfs des
faits les faits comme comment j'ai tué
un état et non et parfois les 20 que je
pourrais demander ce qu'il donnait pas
fait si il accéderait à la magistrature
suprême entendra le défi suivant c'est
que tout ça va me donner c'est qu'ils
prennent vraiment les temps d'établir un
état des doigts l'impunité
il doit réparer la machine judiciaire
il faut qu'ils ramènent les pays
je vraiment sommes en état notamment à
ceret soir les animateurs qui sont
outillés qui au niveau des tickets à
travailler parce qu'on n'oublie pas que
tu as village et la corruption en effet
comme mode de fonctionnement est tout à
fait à ruiner l'économie du pays
et quant au canada dans ses relations
avec la rdc est ce que vous aimeriez
voir quelques changements dans les
prochains mois les prochaines années
avec tout ce qui se passe dans votre vie
maintenant avec sa position qu'ils
appuient ce que leur prise de
l'ambassade du canada à kinshasa où il
est à la barre sa saleen mais les
congolais exige que les résultats des
urnes réflète levé convenait et plus
loin il faut reconnaître que le canada
est parmi les pays qui accueillent plus
de convoler
c'est douloureux mais ce furent
d'ailleurs à l'ajout d'une souhaité
évoquer le canada est il vraiment une
pause pendant ces fêtes qui a certaines
entreprises canadiennes qui évolue au
congo mais je passe sur le plat aussi de
la diplomatie sur nos plans de
développement il ya plusieurs organismes
canadiens qui y travaille rapidement au
cou et puis aux côtés de convoler
mais il j'aimerais où je souhaite avec
et le canada affichent tous une présence
économique diplomatique se toucher que
c'est pas faux mais est-ce que cela
était déjà le cas pour le canada d'avoir
une présence plus importante à rdc
wiimote et moi je me rappelle dans les
années 30 à l'église de révéler les
canada dit vous voyez pas ce qu'était la
main dans tout ce qui s'est passé au
convoi en tout cas que ce soit du côté
de l'économie a mis de la partie
canadienne il y avait des formations qui
évoluent canadien données en rdc
quand soit au plan de développement du
canada était vraiment prêt et est diffus
que vous parcourez un coin de la rvc
faut voir la bannière du canada voilà
alex vines ça je rappelle que vous êtes
le président de la mutuelle des
congolais de l'étranger
je vous remercie beaucoup d'avoir pris
le temps de nous parler c'est très
gentil c'est très apprécié merci
beaucoup merci alex à la prochaine voilà
voilà donc maintenant revient à nos
recherches vous avez vous a donné un
avant-goût de deux votes refusé de
salaires bas paloma donc vous parler
d'une découverte assez surprenantes
faites au canada quelques qui nous
apprend qu apparemment les effets d un
ti breizh antidépresseurs se
transmettent de génération en génération
exactement au cours d'une recherche sous
les effets d'un antidépresseur utilisé
par les humains sur la pré production
des poissons zèbre les biologistes de
l'univers de biologie de l'université
d'ottawa ont découvert quelque chose qui
a changé complètement le cours de l'or
de leurs recherches ils sont vu que la
présence de résidus de du prozac qui
c'est un dessin est très souvent utilisé
par les humains dans le milieu de vie
des poissons étudiés a résulté un niveau
très bas des corps thyssen toutefois les
les corti seul c'est une substance qu'il
n'observe aux produits pour faire face
au stress
c'est à dire ça produisent les stress
pour qu'on s'adapte aux réalités
convient de lui donc ce poisson là sont
confrontés sont exposés à cette
substance là et puis à mes temps exposé
assez souple sans cela ne répond plus de
la même manière à l'environnement qui
les entoure
c'est à dire qu'il est sain tôt par
contre et par an ce qui veut dire ce que
les poissons qui devait normalement
faire face à une réalité données ne
peuvent plus le faire parce qu'ils sont
pas adaptés sont plus adaptées parce que
leur niveau de cortisol est très bas
semblent s'en sont pas assez stressé
ces poissons là c'est à dire donc c'est
très important comme com
mais oui alors donc mal constaté au
niveau des poissons mais est-ce que ça a
été on va ou ailleurs est ce que c'était
transfuse voyez où je veux en venir
c'est que j'ai passé à
un des chercheurs monsieur ben vance
trudeau de l'université d'ottawa je lui
dise qu'on peut voir ces mêmes s'est
fait chez les êtres humains il ne peut
pas s'avancer pour l'instant parce que
il est bien biologiste et s'intéresse
vraiment à la hausse et poissons là en
particulier mais ce qui a été
particulièrement importante dans la
recherche ce qui on a vu que ça se voit
le résultat laisse effet se voit de
génération en génération donc la
première génération des poissons exposés
à ces ascètes à cette substance la ne
s'adaptent pas me lis la génération
suivante 50 s'adapte encore moins à
cette substance là ça veut dire que sur
le long terme
c'est préoccupant parce que ces poissons
risquent de disparaître parce qu'un
people ils ne peuvent pas s'adapter à la
dérobée à l'heure à leur enterrement
très très intéressant que tous les
humains il va falloir attendre mais
j'imagine que c'est un fait les il faut
regarder les faits on les fait désirer
les centres des pressages chez les êtres
humains parce que souvent les cartes
seules et les stress ne sont pas un
problème c'est que on doit faire face à
du stress il nécessaire parfois est donc
donc ce jose la rd l'ailé mais parce que
quand même très intéressant comme projet
de richesse qui vous ont dit si ils
comptent observer du côté des humains
aubry se contente juste du poisson
biolog et daf à encourager d'autres à
aller sur une piste probable m moi ce
que je dis j'ai demandé aux chercheurs
c'est que s'il y avait d'autres de ses
collègues qui seraient intéressés à
suivre pour suivre ça au niveau des
humains il m'a dit on va laisser le
temps à passer encore il que les
recherches continuent d'évoluer parce
que leurs recherches à eux et tout et
tout petit mais elle peut continuer
d'évoluer avec d'autres ils peuvent
continuer d'observer ccpz mm s'est fait
sur d'autres espèces
donc il m'a dit c'est pas tout de suite
on fait ça
ça ne m'était très intéressant très
facilement et vous pouvez aller le voir
et le revoir lire écouter les entrevues
des extraits d'entrevues sur notre site
rci net et saynètes danses essayez donc
merci beaucoup mais c'est pas le paloma
alors maryse donc on revient à notre
sujet notre sujet qui a c'est assez
fascinant donc un sujet sur oman un an
famille particulier à l'asie
alors la personne j'ai interviewé
s'appelle sébastien [ __ ]
on sait qu'aujourd'hui prononcer ce mot
là en amérique c'est porteur de sens
c'est très négatif
il faut savoir que lui sa famille ce nom
là est dans la famille depuis 500 ans et
que de l'endroit où il est originaire le
languedoc qui trouve au bord de la
méditerranée entre une partie en france
eh bien ça voulait dire salies du mot
immigré monténégro pense au monténégro
montagne noire et les gens qui se
faisaient appeler négre est en fait
c'étaient des gens qui avaient des
cheveux foncés et la peau un peu plus
basané et ça donne lieu à toutes sortes
de trucs comme par exemple lui il fait
du travail pour radio rurale
internationale en afrique il est allé en
afrique plusieurs fois il s'est retrouvé
une fois à l'aéroport et il donne son
nom à la personne sébastien [ __ ]
alors là il ya un grand monsieur qui est
africain derrière lui qui dit tiens il
est comme moi l automne ans met à rire
ou encore il arrive dans un village là
bas pour donner de l'aide pour enseigner
les rudiments de la radio pour donner
des cours et là on ne peut pas parler de
son nom pendant quatre ou cinq jours et
après on a dit mais le [ __ ] comment se
fait il que tu te retrouves avec ce nom
et c'est franchement très intéressant et
maintenant à montréal
alors ce qu'il dit c'est que souvent on
l'appelait monsieur sébastien ou
sébacées monde de la peinture sur verre
à la main qu'ils trouvent ça drôle ou
encore est ce que comme le mot est tabou
donc
d'ailleurs il avait une carte de
fidélité ils voulaient s'inscrire est là
il reçoit un message votre nom n'est pas
conforme alors le gars fait il appel au
service client et qu'il explique son cas
que sa famille à ce nom là depuis 501 et
que c'était ok qui s'appelle comme ça
alors qu'ils ont débloqué ça les faisait
qu'il n'est pas noir du tout maintenant
peut-être à l'origine bondi convient
tous du continent noir à l'origine
peut-être mais sa famille porte ce nom
là et ce qui est drôle c'est que pendant
certaines années ils ont vécu aussi en
tunisie
alors il y en a une histoire dans sa
famille de deux liens avec l'afrique
et puis tout ça je ne racontais j'ai
fait comme ça par hasard en bouquin une
autre entrevue
et là je me suis dit est possible de ne
pas lui poser des questions sur son
antenne
bah oui vous allez bon quelqu'un qui
s'appelle blague this morale à cuba
comme blake est plus générique a pas
plus c'est moins controversé ce que noir
par exemple monsieur noir met d'ailleurs
mais dans son village dans son village
d'origine
il y avait dans la même rue la famine
est de la famille blanc et la famille
mar ont cassé toutes les couleurs presse
etc sont représentés dans cette rue est
ce que je vous dis je vous garantis
c'est vrai alors je vous invite à
écouter l'entrevue qui sera sur le site
web un peu plus tard cet après-midi
s'est passé des questions concernant ce
qui est accepté politiquement dans la
société actuellement il ya beaucoup de
choses que l'on dit pas parce qu'on veut
pas offenser donc le nom c'est pour ça
que j'ai rien quand les gens l'appeler
monsieur sébastien parce que d'habitude
quand on connaît pas quelqu'un en
adresse on s'adresse à cette personne en
parlant de seulement 1 en nommant son
nom de famille mais dans son cas c'était
pour né pas l'offenser mais c'est son
nom de famille ces particules sans
penser une anecdote dans
une garderie enfin on garde une école
primaire alors il ya des enfants qui
passent et moi j'étais là parce que bon
j'avais quelqu'un à prendre et là une
petite fille qu'il me voie qui parle à
son père après bon et dit elle et elle
monsieur qui la voulait pas dire le
monsieur de noir elle hésitait poussée
de trouver un synonyme anwar quel âge
avait-elle x 4 5 1 voilà c'est ça elle
essaie de trouver nulle
ça faisait beaucoup de m beaucoup de
peine plus non non c'est noir c'est noir
et le monsieur noah donc je suis noir la
fota et comment at-elle réagi
bon il était soulagé parce qu'elle
essaie de trouver une bonne façon de
dire la chose et puis voilà je vais
jouer son inconfort il n'y a pas de
problème à dire que je suis noir mais il
y avait personne
les enfants c'est plus tard dans la
jambe dans leur vie de jeudi que qui
vont faire une différence par rapport à
la couleur de la peau c'est le sel
environnement souvent qui va qui va
faire que les gens se rendent compte de
la différence au début il se fera contre
les jeunes ce qui est pas loin d'un
exode justement une autre anecdote d'un
couple il avait un enfant depuis le très
bas âge une fille qu'il apparaît habite
d'un ami un ami à l'école à la garderie
à l'école primaire au secondaire tout le
temps ce que le même ami et qu'elle a de
valou cégep et décide de faire une fête
est donc d'inviter cette amie la
séparant 10 mai depuis des années que
tous nous en parle
ce serait une très bonne chose que
d'habitude cette année là dont ils ne
parlent tout le temps
et quand la nuit est venue les parents
étaient très surpris de constater que
c'est un noir or depuis à peu près 10 15
ans n'a jamais fait allusion à ça a la
couleur
et quand la fête est finie l'enfer parc
de la mire parti et les allées les
parents demandent à leur fille mais
pourquoi tu n'as jamais dit que c'était
il était noir
et là les parents mondiaux vaille et le
contexte a changé parce qu'à notre
époque
une des premières choses qu'on aurait
dit à nos parents c'est de dire mais
j'ai des amis noirs qui ont de tels pays
issus du sud n'a jamais allégeant ses
origines mais pas plutôt de ses qualités
de ce qu'elle aime en lui de ce qu'ils
font ensemble c'est tout et pas de la
couleur de la peau j'ai entendu une fois
un écrivain ici au québec à dire qu'elle
halfon il voulait toujours se concentrer
sur ce qui nous rassemble est donc pas
sur les choses qui nous différencie mais
surtout sur les choses qui nous qui nous
font être des êtres humains puis
seulement des êtres humains peu importe
d'où on vient
en même temps c'est sûr que on laissait
trop mais on a une grande fierté a parlé
de nos solides et notre culture de notre
langue etc
mais dans le fond ça change quoi ça
change quoi ça change beaucoup de choses
mais je dis dans les relations humaines
si ce n'est vraiment pas ce qu'on est
habitué avant l'habitude aux gens qui
nous ressemblent on a grandi dans un
environnement de sept nouveaux génies tu
es donc toutes nos références sont liées
aux gens qui nous ressemblent et donc
parfois la différence d'entrée de jeu
n'aurait but et après c'est ce premier
que ses premiers effets on se rend
compte qu'au fond finalement la d1 en
face de nous des êtres humains aussi
différents que les membres de notre
famille que de notre entourage s'est
diversifié dans la façon de voir de
penser ainsi de suite c'est intéressant
parce que c est un lien aussi avec le
fait que maintenant il ya des gens qui
disent ne plus dire monsieur ou madame
nous inversons exactement parce que les
gens rient deviez problématique on vous
alors une réflexion à faire là-dessus
peut-être mais oui une autre bombe
l'addition une chose qui ait voulu aussi
baisser la cuisine de mets de la cuisine
la chronique de marie marie claude marie
claude
oui ça depuis plusieurs mois déjà fini
koné culinat qui s'appelle cuisine je me
souviens donc à chaque fois je vais à la
rencontre de quelqu'un qui me parle
souvent ça des passionnés de cuisine
mais qui sont pas des professionnels
nécessairement d'eux
la gastronomie et puis les gens me
parlent d'un blog qu'ils aiment et des
souvenirs qui sont rattachés alors
souvent ça nous donne l'occasion de
parler bon de l'enfance de la personne
et de son pays d'origine de sa famille
alors je n'ai le mans culture est
importante
oui la gastronomie perd plus c'est une
façon tellement conviviale et
chaleureuse de finalement de découvrir
quelqu'un découvrir une culture mais
j'adore faire ça paie en plus souvent je
vais chez les personnes alors maintenant
l'environnement alors ça pour dire que
demain la première de 2019 temps des
pêches peux pas vraiment vous les
montrer ce qu'elle sait pas si mais on
sait déjà que ça va être sûr mais qui
s'appelle l'acte s ouais tu te le
montrer
là où toutes les sortes chronique se
trouve pacifique
j'aime cette vidéo si mais je sais pas
son altesse vraiment c'est beaucoup de
temps ça va tant que ça je vais vous
parler des lattes caisse et les galettes
de pommes de terre qui sont servis
pendant la fête juive de souccot donc au
mois de décembre
s'arrêter bien qu'elles sortent au mois
de décembre mais on l'a on sent la
chronique au mois de janvier parce
qu'elle est la base de toute façon on
peut enfin toute l'année
alors voilà des transferts c'est comme
les pâtés à la viande au québec on peut
n'en font plus de manger à l'année
normalement sa maman pourquoi pas et
puis donc je suis allée chez une
montréalaise qui s'appelle marcisz la
coff et puis à montrer comment ils le
faisaient d'organes de donner ici on a
une petite vidéo d'une minute qui nous
montre avec avec avec musique si on veut
oui parce qu'ils nous montrent comment
ça fonctionne
on y va ce que son
vous rappellez patate surtout paul et
les râper aux cuisines à rouen un robot
que ce soit fait à la map
je connais ça parlement les cuisines
heures non mais là les lattes est ce
parce que la demande est lara lorsque je
ressemble à la robe que ma mère avait
justement c'était la robe de sa grand
mère on a parlé beaucoup de ça voilà et
puis
voilà il ya des oeufs de la farine du
sel la poudre à
la poudre à pâte ce n'est pas sucré
c'est plus sympa par contre peut les
servir avec de la compote de pommes et
puis on les fait frire dans le ville lui
c'est un aliment
c'est un ingrédient symbolique car en
tout cas parce que ce sera le cas
célèbre le miracle de la fiole d'huile
j'irai pas je vous conterai pas le corps
voilà c'est important et ça ce qui est
de lui
la voilà mais c'est délicieux qu'un peu
ses distances
ça nourrit bien la voilà avec la compote
de pommes
oyo gourou du yoga audio et les deux
comme ça à la voix leur voix le monorail
si ces lâches la fameux chandelier à
huit branches mem france cette part
voilà à sept branches on y va plus
intéressant le temps de cuisson c'est à
peu près combien de temps un peu on va
dire ça doit être
je la vois tout ce qu'il a à faire 45
baisse parce que c'est vraiment pénible
de rap et tout ça mais ça vaut la peine
parce que ça donne la liberté que ça pue
c'est trois quatre minutes par côté les
est-ce qu'on peut le faire à la friteuse
il faut des renseignements sur la toile
mais la substance même de faire mieux
mais ça se consomme tout ça comme ça ou
bien c'est la loose ou non c'est pas mal
tout seul parce tu peux avoir des fruits
avec ça mais c'est plus pour un brunch
là je vous montrais la page tant qu'à
faire faire la publicité pour ma
chronique
alors on y va alors
j'avais fait aussi bon le
ryan dunn les cretons on avait le homard
ici vous voyez en bas on a des gens de
calais tout ce qui ressemble un peu aux
l'adq scd la période des farçous vérone
parce qu'il faut nous faut nous dire
parce que ça vienne d'un peu partout
donc ces gens de montréal ou du canada
ce qu'il ya le homard je les fais un
nouveau monde rick et c'est des gens
d'ici mais qui souvent sont un bagage
culturel différent je vois quelque chose
de mots à coucy exactement à kahnawake
et puis regardez ici ça ça vous fait
penser à quelque chose
oui le lait d'eau les wii ou sais pas si
je peux faire un lien avec quelque chose
d'ici mais c'est sa base de légumes
c'est des légumes avec des arachides
vous savez les harrachis de le lire ici
ça sert beaucoup plus comme une espèce
de tartinades mais à l'afrique c'est une
base un élément culinaire très important
pour un problématique du compte il faut
savoir mettre la technique parce qu'à la
base c'est une herbe roues après une
plante qui est amer oui exactement
elle a en trop de l'apprêter de la bonne
façon bouillir plusieurs fois pour
enlever la meule toute une journée
c'est quels légumes quels fruits ou clic
le dos les quitte donc la question du
dessus est ce que vous en faites
en avez vous déjà faire moi donc
impossible entre de votre mère passait
largement de l'amener compétences
culinaires
ici on voit que
c'est celle qui faisait le dos les bras
on est donc donnée maintenant elle est
grave les arracher leur associe c'est
quelque chose qui c'est mieux de faire à
la main kokoro beau mais c'est plus long
alors c'est comme les lads caisse et
c'est physique
[Rires]
vous savez déjà fait des choses des
chroniques en lien avec avec l'amérique
latine aussi je savais qu'en me demander
y a qu'à ma première chronique c'était
pour noël l'année dernière toute une
affaire
selon koné palais sayaka ça c'est des
crêpes de maïs qui sont farcis avec de
la viande est tout ça mais ensuite sur
les enveloppes dans une feuille de
banane des bananiers et puis ensuite je
les fais bouillir à l'appui c'est le
goût de la feuille de bananier bouillir
oui c'était la vapeur comme l'état
malais ce nom mais elle elle le faisait
carrément dans les phases les méthodes
dando
carrément mais j'imagine kiev puis il ya
beaucoup d'autres cultures aussi qui
utilise les feuilles de bananier qu'ils
y font des fois vous allez va pas aussi
mal oui c'est ça dans les cultures on va
en robes il rit dans lequel on a mis
d'autres massacres médian on va faire
bouillir
ça donne le goût très particulier on en
a mangé à notre dîner de noël parce que
nos collègues place de l'équipe chinoise
allons apporter
d'ailleurs c'est la nouvelle année
chinoise chinoise qui s'en vient je veux
vraiment avoir je sais pas si vous avez
je demande à nos collègues de la section
chinoise mais j'aimerais vraiment faire
quelque chose de plus sur une chaîne
chinoise s'est faite comme moi tu vas
tuer facilement si je pense puis
totalement parce que ça fait beaucoup
c'était environ au sud est c'était fini
la ceni le magnifique
l'important c'est qu'on trouve contre le
sujet on trouve un contact et puis voilà
voilà
parce que oui c'est vraiment c'est juste
la joie de partager puis deux
c'est drôle lorsqu'on parle de cuisine
livres de cuisine moi j'ai encore
j'hérite et de ma mère son vieux livres
de cuisine qui s'appelle la cuisine
raisonnée
il a été réédité pour ses saintes et
elle est à noter comme par exemple les
carrés aux dattes
elle met plus de date donc j'ai son
écriture à la main ouais
jallet d'ailleurs salle yves lacam à la
donne et c'est un crime et lorsqu'on
clarté un appartement elle nous donnait
aussi le livre de cuisine de gm benoît
où l'on apprend tout au long de l'année
sort alors c'était comme une tradition
dans la famille maintenant on comprend
le secret de vous vos performances
extraordinaires en cuisine si on avait
plus de temps par exemple c'est la
taille mannequin
mais le plus qu'on prépare les mieux
qu'on mange froid se rachètent les
choses déjà tout fait mais on perd on
perd en qualité d'aliments et ça c'est
un dilemme pour le new way tout le monde
qui travaille cinq jours semaine et qui
fait toutes sortes de choses souci voilà
alors sur ce mesdames c'est une émission
très féminine aujourd'hui on a eu ce
monsieur baroin doit tout à l'heure mais
bon c'était comme d'habitude très très
agréable marit marie-claude bon je
remercie beaucoup pas louvard et maryse
alors mais dieu merci à vous mais la
mission s'est dit à une prochaine
bye
d